from reading to read were G Robinson who  achieved greatness as a player a patron  of the arts and a dedicated citizen in  some a Renaissance man from his friends  in the industry he loved ladies and  gentlemen  mrs. Edgar G Robinson  Thank You Chuck my husband knew he was  to be honored tonight and he prepared  his face may I read what he wrote it  couldn't have come at a better time in a  man's life had it come earlier it would  have aroused deep feelings in me still  not so deep as now I am very grateful to  my rich warm creative talented intimate  colleagues who have been my life's  associates how much richer can you be  thank you for Eddie